puisqu'on va démarrer en parlant de nos
rêves alors est ce qui vous arrive
d'abord de vous souvenir de vos rêves
les uns et les autres
sam arguments pour quasiment tout le
temps qu'un résidant à bon on va
développer ça ensemble juste après parce
qu'il existera figurez-vous pour ceux
qui n'y arrivent pas il y aurait un
moyen très simple pour s'en souvenir et
c'est bfm tv qui nous le révèle il peut
se souvenir de ses rêves
oui on peut sans souci majeur la clé
c'est de prendre son temps
vous prenez votre temps pour vous
endormir vous prenez votre temps pour
vous lever le matin tout est une
question de noradrénaline c'est
l'hormone
oui qui va nous aider à nous lever le
matin et bien plus vous la laisse est
arrivé plus vous vous souvenez de vos
rêves
bon alors qu'est ce qu'on en pense et ce
que vous pensez qu'en appliquant cette
méthode vous arriveriez à vous souvenir
devoir être nommé le mec il a été payé
pour dire ça ah bon c'est abusé oui
c'est abusé à bon d'accord parce que je
pense que c'est c'est pas du tout lié à
un truc comme ça au ralentissement du
matin de chances que ce non sens que je
pense qu on peut se souvenir de ses
rêves
c'est très sympa ton souvenir et une
fois qu on s'en souvient ce qui est très
sympa c'est d'aller chercher la
signification veille pas forcément à lui
est parfois ya des rêves qui sont
récurrents par grange rêve très souvent
oui de vous nous met tous les clubs est
donc en fait ce qui est je suis venu
avec une veste
est-ce que tu coules dans le rêve on
reprend aussi les éléments qui existe
vraiment dans la réalité c'est vrai je
porte souvent presque tout le problème
c'est qu'après alesi avec la
signification il ya plein de
signification parce que la nuit tombe on
recommence à la réalité la lave est la
leur dans mon inconscient je pense qu'il
ya quelque chose comme ça qui est qui
est gravé et au delà de ça après c'est
mon imagination qui s'était bien sûr
mais ça a causé des choses ou jetés
comme entre voulait vraiment seulement
voilà que vous étiez vraiment un plateau
nu a bien sûr oui vraiment
mais si vous étiez bonne et un salaire
de vous surprendre par don qui vous avez
alors que soit je tombe amoureuse de
vous ah ça c'est une première au troquet
soit rêver d'une femme nue ça annonce la
fortune assurée ah bah voilà pour qui
bat pour vous peut-être mais à chaque
fois ça symbolise un manque de confiance
en moi et l'impression que vous vous
sous-estimez si elle demande à ce que va
nous dire de vous faire des compléments
et tout s'était très d'accord très bien
d'accord je suis la seule dont vous
rêvez onu pour l'équipe vaut mieux vaut
mieux non
j'ai rêvé aussi de lui dit non mais
laissez moi tranquille cas de jimmy ah
oui c'est vrai d'accord ok très bien ça
s'explique d'accord mais pas de jean
michel cohen
non mais il ya deux saisons quand même
les vertus de certaines plantes qui sont
étonnants mais pas du tout mais j'ai un
gros blocage j'aimerais bien prendre
justement donc ça m'a intéressé sujet
j'ai trouvé un peu bizarre parce que je
me suis dit que finalement en me levant
à 3h45 pour les matinales
c'était peut-être ça le qui me bloquait
wekiss arrête de bosser là voyons jusque
là je vais commencer on dit également
qu'il faudrait peut-être avoir sur la
table de chevet un petit carnet est
notée 'a' dans une sorte de demi
conscience ce que l'on aurait à peine
rêver bah c'est un peu ça parce qu'en
fait tout le monde rêve on rêve tous
on s'en souvient pas tous y aller une
grand rêveur qui se souviennent et
qu'ils généralement le sommeil vous
savez on peut fractionner part qu'il
faut se réveiller la nuit effectivement
et là le cerveau a plus le temps
d'enregistrer moi je suis une ancienne
grande rêveuse mais aujourd'hui je pense
que je dors trop bien travaux et je
m'excuse mais incapable de me souvenir
de mes rêves d'accord ou alors vous avez
tout verrouillé c'est peut-être
inconscient qui verront les théoriciens
mieux que je ne sois pas également comme
karolina vous voir nulle louis-blanc
arrêté de me voir à quoi elle tout ça
vraiment ça suffit mais un peu de pudeur
mars
on voit des dites nous ce que vous en
pensez avec le hashtag sécu dlt dit non
également si vous avez des rêves
peut-être récurrents ou des rêves
prémonitoires ou ou si vous êtes
également allé de chercher du côté du
symbole puisque on dit que par exemple
le serpent c'est l'argent les danses et
le sexe qu'est-ce qui a d'autres encore
la nudité donc ce serait ce que vous
m'avez dit la fortune ou bien
l'inconfort c'est à dire qu'on n'est pas
assez à l'aise dans ses baskets bref dit
nous c'est super intéressant et je suis
certaine que vous avez des anecdotes à
nous raconter et enfin et surtout éviter
le réveil brutal si vous voulez vous
souvenir de vos rêves
[Applaudissements]
mais moi j'ai tout fait rien arrêter
encore on survit à ça on peut tuer
surtout d'accord on est d'accord